- [Pranjit] Hello, everyone.
Welcome to NTA404 and
welcome to re:Invent.
I hope you all are having some fun
with all the nice sessions just for you.
My name is Pranjit, I'm
a solution architect,
and I have with me my co-speaker.
- [Marcus] Marcus Mattson,
also a solutions architect.
And I hope everyone's
having a good day one.
Everyone doing all right,
enjoying its sessions?
(audience applauding)
All right, good deal.
- Nice and thank you, again,
for spending the next one hour with us.
So today's topic is AI Code to
Production: Context Matters.
How many of you, like if I have
a quick raise of your hands,
how many of you are using some kind
of AI coding assistant to code?
Quite a few. Okay, nice.
How many of you have started
playing or dabbling around
with our agentic IDE tool, Kiro?
Okay, not bad. Okay, all right.
So in today's session,
what we're gonna cover
is, this is a code talk,
so we're gonna do a lot of
coding while you are here.
But before that, just
to set the stage today,
we're gonna talk about some
of the AI code production problem.
Like when you build, like
when you do vibe coding
or you are doing some
kind of prompt engineering
and creating some nice
code, what is the challenge
that typically happens
when they go in production
and how we can like do context engineering
to kind of put those code,
make this code like production ready?
And then, the next thing
that we're gonna cover is
we're gonna talk about some
of the essential context
layers for your success
when you are building AI code.
And then, some of the key takeaways
from today's session,
some of the workshops
that we want to highlight
that you can get started with.
So having said that,
let's quickly talk about a
developer named Sarah, okay?
She's a senior developer.
She started doing vibe coding,
and she faced some challenges.
Let's see what are the
challenges that she faced
and how she overcomes that.
- [Narrator] Let's talk about a journey
that I think every
developer knows deep down.
It's the move
from that frantic,
adrenaline-fueled, last-minute hack
to the calm confidence you get
from building something
you know is rock solid.
It's really a story
about the hidden dangers
of just making it work.
You know the feeling, right?
It's Friday afternoon, a huge
deadline is staring you down,
and the only thing anyone cares
about is getting something,
anything up and running
for that demo.
That pressure, well, that's exactly
where our story kicks off.
All right, so let's set the scene.
This first part is all about a gamble.
It's about a very tempting
but also very dangerous way
of developing software, especially now
that we've all got these
incredibly powerful AI tools right
at our fingertips.
So let's meet Sarah.
She's a talented developer.
She knows her stuff.
But right now, she's
completely up against the wall.
A really critical demo
is just a few hours away,
and she needs a miracle fast.
So what does she do?
She dives into what we're
gonna call vibe coding.
She's just firing off prompts
to her AI tool, grabbing the
code snippets it spits out,
and stitching them together
based on her gut feeling.
There's no big architectural
plan, no deep thinking.
It's all about speed,
and that feeling of, "Yeah,
yeah, that looks about right."
And you know what? It totally works.
The demo goes off without a hitch.
The feature is a hit, the
stakeholders are thrilled,
and Sarah's the hero of the hour.
She pulled it off.
But that amazing feeling,
that rush of confidence, well,
it's kinda built on sand.
Of course, that Friday high,
yeah, it doesn't last long.
Because the nice, clean, predictable world
of a demo is nothing
like the absolute chaos
of a live production environment.
And this, this is where
that shortcut comes back
to bite her hard.
This is when reality hits.
Monday morning rolls around,
the code gets pushed live,
and almost instantly,
alarms start going off.
The whole thing, the system
that worked so beautifully
in the demo just completely
falls apart under the weight
of real users and real-world data.
It is an absolute catastrophe.
And look at the kinds of
problems we're talking about.
These are not simple bugs.
These are the deep, gnarly
architectural nightmares.
You've got race conditions
corrupting data,
massive security holes,
compliance failures,
and memory leaks that are
crashing servers left and right.
These are the huge, invisible icebergs
that vibe coding just sails straight into.
And this is the moment
it all clicks for Sarah.
This is her big aha moment.
The AI wasn't the problem at all.
It did exactly what she told it to do.
The problem was she didn't
know what to ask for.
She asked for a feature, sure,
but what she actually needed
was a production-ready system.
And those are two
completely different things.
So this total disaster, it
becomes a massive turning point.
Sarah realizes she just
can't work like this anymore.
It's time to evolve, to level up
from being a reactive vibe coder
into something way more
intentional, way more powerful,
a context architect.
Now, let's be super clear.
This isn't about her throwing
out her AI tools. No way.
It's about getting way
smarter in how she uses them.
It's a shift from just
asking for a chunk of code
to providing the AI with deep,
rich, structural context,
so it can generate code
that's not just working
but is genuinely robust.
So how does she actually make the shift?
Well, she adopts a new framework.
You can think of it like a
blueprint for success, a way
to feed the AI all the right information
from the very start.
Let's walk through these
four layers of architecture
that pretty much changed
everything for her.
Okay, here's how this blueprint works.
It all starts with requirements.
This is where she thinks through
every possible edge case,
every failure mode, all that security
and compliance stuff.
Next up is design.
Here, she's planning
things like concurrency
to avoid those exact race conditions
that burned her before.
Then, comes implementation,
building the code from day one,
so that it's easy to
observe, scale, and maintain.
And finally, the operational layer.
This is where she's thinking
ahead about monitoring
for things like memory leaks
before it becomes a five-alarm fire.
This table really just lays
it all out, doesn't it?
On one side, you have the vibe coder.
They're reactive, they use vague prompts,
and they get code that's
good enough for a demo.
They're asking, "What do I build?"
But the context architect is systematic.
They use structured prompts
to get genuinely production-ready code.
They're asking the deeper questions,
"Why are we building this,
"and how will this thing behave
"under every possible kind of stress?"
So armed with this whole new
mindset, Sarah gets a shot
at redemption, and the stakes,
they could not be higher.
Another urgent super critical
request lands on her desk,
but this time, it's right
before the biggest,
most intense traffic day
of the entire year, Black Friday.
But this time is different.
There's no panic. There's
no last-minute vibe coding.
She just calmly and methodically works
through her four layers, building
out a comprehensive plan.
She then uses that plan
to create these incredibly
detailed, context-rich prompts
for her AI assistant,
guiding it to build a system
that is resilient right from its core.
So Black Friday hits.
The website gets absolutely slammed
with a flood of traffic unlike
anything they've ever seen.
The entire team is just
holding their breath, glued
to the monitoring dashboards.
And the number of critical
errors, the number of outages,
the amount of downtime,
it's a big, beautiful zero.
A perfect performance.
The system she so carefully designed
as a context architect
scales up perfectly.
It handles the insane load
without a single hiccup.
I mean, if that's not the ultimate proof
that this new approach
works, I don't know what is.
And really, that's the core
lesson of this whole journey.
The magic isn't the fact that
AI can write code for us.
The real skill, the thing
that truly marks the leap
from a good developer
to a great one is knowing what
context you need to feed it.
And so that brings us
to the final question,
and this one's for you to think about.
The next time that deadline is looming
and the pressure is on,
which one are you gonna be?
Are you gonna be the vibe
coder, crossing your fingers
and just hoping for the best?
Or are you gonna be the context architect,
building for reality?
- [Pranjit] Okay, so having
seen that, right, these are some
of the challenges, right,
of why AI code fails in production.
AI models, they're trained
on a lot of code, right?
But they don't know your business.
There are certain AWS
environment-specific information
that you have in your AWS account,
but it is not aware of it, right?
It is not aware of any kind of regulations
or security compliance, and any kind
of other compliance requirements
that you are supposed to take care of
when you are developing code.
It is not aware of the cost implications.
Are there any challenges
in respect to how you want
to architect your AWS environment
for any production-ready
application, right?
So having said that, these
are some of the context
that we're gonna see how we can address,
like how we can layer this
context into our solution,
which is called Kiro, the
agentic IDE from prototype
to production, which gives
you a lot of flexibility
how you can inject context in runtime,
how you can use the long-term memory
within the application itself
to build something which
you can deploy on day one
in production, right?
So some of them are like
how you can create the business context
and feed that, still utilizing
the entire context window.
Because context window is
something that you don't want
to fill with all your
documents jumping into
and filling all the space
to leave nothing for the LLM
to be creative enough to
come up with something useful
for your production application.
So you need to know
how you can utilize your
context window efficiently
for your production-ready application.
Last but not the least is the AWS context.
So you need to make sure the application
that you're building,
which you're planning
to deploy on AWS, are also
following the best practices.
We call it well-architected
framework, right?
If you have certain cost-related
constraints, you want
to also give that information
to the AI coding assistant
how you can do that.
So all those things, we're
gonna look into the Kiro part
of it and then see how we can use Kiro
and some of the features
that we have in Kiro
to come up with the
production-ready application.
So I'm gonna switch to
my other demo laptop,
and we are gonna talk
about a gaming company.
Let's say Sarah is working
in a gaming company,
and she's supposed to build
a game application, right?
And how she starts introducing context,
how she's utilizing those
contexts to be able to come up
with a production application
that is ready to deploy on AWS.
So with that, I'm gonna switch to my-
- [Marcus] Yeah and if you're like me,
you've seen AI coding assistants generate
some really impressive stuff.
And then, you've seen it create some stuff
that lacked a little bit.
And so you're probably
thinking, "Show me."
And that's what Pranjit's gonna do.
- [Pranjit] All right, can anyone confirm?
Like are you able to see
or do I need to zoom more?
You good? Okay, all right.
So this is the Kiro IDE.
There are two flavors to Kiro.
One is the CLI part of it, one is the IDE.
So if anyone is like familiar
with like coding using
Kiro CLI, you can do that.
Folks who are actually like maybe working
on Visual Studio, it's a VSCode for Kiro.
So you can get all your visual
codes settings onboarded
to Kiro when you are
deploying like installing it
and you're starting to use it.
So for our session, we are
gonna use the Kiro IDE,
not the Kiro CLI, but
you have two flavors.
So just to let you know.
Now, this is a, I've just set the stage.
So what I've done is, initially, I have,
let me, okay,
so I've set a folder called a game app,
and I have placed a Kiro logo over here.
There's just a blank application
with nothing inside it
other than a logo page.
And then, what I'm gonna, if
you see the ghosty icon is
where you would see a lot
of additional features like agent hooks,
you have agent steering,
and you have MCP servers, right?
So we're gonna cover all of them.
Now, in the agent steering,
you see there's a global
steering rule called
spec global rules, which is a condition
that I put for all my applications
that I'm gonna build
with Kiro agentic IDE.
So what I want is this is
the global steering rule.
So how do you, when you actually
go into the agent steering
and hit this plus button,
you have like three options over here.
The first one is creating from scratch
where if you have any code base
already there in this repo,
if not, it's gonna create
some basic markdown files.
There's one which is called
global agent steering,
and there's one
foundational steering rule.
So for the one that I'm showing here,
it is the global agent steering.
That means it is stored in the home folder
of Kiro under steering.
So that way, this global
rules are applicable
for any application that
I build through Kiro,
and I'm gonna show how
it is going to take you.
So I have given like a
specific information of that
when I'm gonna use spec-driven
development instead of vibe.
Always create the requirements
markdown document,
and then also list
different personas, right?
When actually the requirements
documents are created,
it doesn't give the personas,
but I want that the user stories
and the acceptance criteria
that it creates should have
a persona attached to it.
I also want, like when it is
creating a design document,
it also should include a ER
or entity relationship diagram for me
if there's a database
schema involved, right?
And then, the other one is like
when it is creating the task,
it should also organize the
task so that like after each
and every granular task, I should be able
to like demo a unit test.
Like what exactly the
application looks like
after this task, right?
So for our project, what I'm gonna do is
I'll go back to this folder structure.
Bear with me.
So I'm gonna create a
specific steering rule.
Steering rules are
something that is specific
to this application.
It is always going to refer
to the steering rules when
it is trying to come up
with the requirements and
the design and the task.
So let me create it from scratch.
Building rules, so these are my standards
that I always want Kiro
to take care of when it is
building an application.
So it comes with this template.
It has inclusion always on the top.
That means it is always going
to include the specific instructions
that I'm gonna put over here
when it is trying to come up
with the requirements in our design.
So I'm gonna paste it over here.
So what I've done is like I've mentioned,
let's say game-building application rules.
When you are a helpful
game-building agent,
you must always adhere to
like the preferred languages.
So let's say you are like
creating any Python application.
So you can put those
specific information specific
to your scenario, but
you can give any number
of information based on what
your like standards are,
what your company standards
are, what kind of coding rules
that you follow.
So you can give all these over here,
and then I'm gonna save it.
And I'm gonna create
one more markdown file,
which is specific to
the styling part of it.
So what kind of colors that I want
and anything related to design.
So I'm gonna come here.
And then, I'm gonna create one more.
Styling guide, all right.
And then, I'm gonna paste it over here.
So if you see over here,
I've given like specific color schemas
and some of the uses guidelines
and some design guidelines
that I like to adhere
when I'm actually building
this gaming application.
Now, I will switch to vibe.
So as I mentioned, right,
Kiro gives you flexibility.
So there are certain scenarios
where vibe coding is relevant.
Like if you want to
build a quick prototype,
vibe coding is still
the go-to path, right?
If you're building something,
which is production ready,
definitely advise to
use spec-based coding,
which follows the typical SDLC process
of like planning first
rather than just prompting
and praying like vibe coding, right?
So that it gives you the right code.
Because like typically in vibe coding,
what happens is that when
you give a big prompt
with all the information, it starts coding
without even thinking.
And then, the code that it comes out,
you probably have to like revise it.
So you go back and ask,
"Okay, can you add this?"
And then, it goes and tries to address
that specific last chat history,
and then it forgets what
it has created initially.
And then, you go into regression
and you keep on troubleshooting to come up
with like a code that you
can really play with, right?
Whereas in spec-based is more
of like doing all the planning,
making sure they are approved like either
by your product manager
or your architect team,
or even if it is you
are a senior developer
and you have the ownership
to approve all the use cases.
And then, you start
then building the code,
so that the code that is
being built is adhering
to all the requirements and a design
that you have approved, right?
So that's kinda the difference
between vibe and spec-based.
All right, now-
- [Marcus] So just a quick one
on these documents you just
created, the steering docs,
the rules basically.
The global are gonna be your
organizational standards.
- Yeah.
- And the others are specific
to this project, and one
of those was marked always.
So that means whether you're using vibe
or spec, it's gonna refer back
to those steering doc rules?
- [Pranjit] Yes, so you
can set certain guidelines
at the global steering level,
and then you have certain guidelines
at the like WorkSpace level, right?
But then, typically, the
WorkSpace-level steering, like
if there's a collision between the global
and the WorkSpace, the
global steering rules are
not getting the precedence.
It's basically the
WorkSpace-specific guidelines
that takes precedence in respect
to what it is going to build, right?
So that's how that
takes precedence, right?
So yeah, good question. Thanks, Marcus.
Okay, now, I just have
an idea of this game
that I want to build.
I want to build a Flappy Kiro game, right?
Now, I can use vibe to just go
and ask like, "Build a very basic version
"for my prototype for my ideation," right?
So maybe I can start with vibe instead
of like starting with the spec-based.
So I have an idea and I
paste a prompt over here,
and if you see I just mentioned,
"I want to build a Flappy Kiro game.
"Please, create a very
basic working version."
I've given some information like
what kind of canvas you
should use for rendering.
Kiro character, I mentioned
there is an image over there
in the documents, so it can refer to that.
So I've given some basic information.
I just did vibe coding,
and I told, "Okay, go and do for me."
Now, while it is building that,
like while it is coming up
with the code, if you see over here,
there are certain options.
Like one is the autopilot.
So autopilot in the sense
I've given some autonomy
to this agentic IDE, so
that it can take some like,
it can take some actions
without even asking me
or prompting me, okay,
approve for everything.
If I toggle that off, it's
gonna ask me for everything
that it does on the code base, right?
There are options
of like selecting
different models from here.
Like you can select Opus
model. You can select Claude.
Or you can go in auto mode,
so that like the agentic
IDE can decide based
on what kind of context
and what kind of task
that it is doing.
It can toggle between
different models, right?
So for me, I've selected
Claude 4.5, so I stick to that.
And then, the other option
is there's an option
of adding images.
So let's say you are
coming out of a meeting.
You did a whiteboarding
of a gaming application,
and you took a picture
of maybe an ERD diagram
that you have drawn out in the meeting.
Or you might have drawn
an architecture diagram
with your stakeholders, right?
You can take a picture and
you can upload it over here,
and then you can ask Kiro to
kind of come up with a plan.
So it has like a
multimodal feature as well
where you can take some images
and put it into the context to come up
with those requirements for you, right?
So it can do that.
Now, if you see over here, it has,
this is what I wanted to show you.
So when it started like vibe coding,
it included the steering documents.
So the one is the global one,
and then a couple of them
that I mentioned I created specific
to this WorkSpace, right?
And then, it says,
"Okay, let's build the
Flappy game together."
So it went ahead, and
it created some stuff.
So if I go back here in this one, it,
let's see, once you answer this, okay,
so it is asking me to answer.
So I'll create a playable
version and all the games.
So it is asking.
So if you see over here,
what I mentioned over here in
the app building rules, right?
I asked that suggest creative ways,
and then take user's input
and create a user context MD steering file
to store user preferences as
you help the user build a game.
So it just didn't go
and started creating code just
like vibe coding does, right?
So now, it is asking me, okay,
can you address this portion
that I have for you before
even I go and code, right?
So that's why like you are
actually acting as a driver
in the seat, not giving the whole autonomy
to the IDE tool to come
and create the code, right?
So maybe let me give some
instructions over here, right?
So what Visual Studio do you prefer?
So let's say classic Flappy Bird game.
And then, it says obstacle.
What should the obstacles
look like? Traditional.
And then, scoring, how
should scoring work?
Plus one point based on
survival time, all right?
So I've given that information,
and then Kiro goes and starts.
Okay, so now it has started
the HTML page for the game.
And if you see over here,
it has started appearing over here.
And then, it has started
creating the JavaScript.
So once it is created, we're gonna look
into the code itself.
So let me go here, and then
let's see what it is building.
- [Marcus] Yeah, it's starting
to already give us hints
that this could start to become
a more complex application.
It's asking about user preferences,
and you're starting to wonder
maybe vibe coding is not going
to be enough.
So let's see what it's
got put together so far.
- [Pranjit] So it has, yeah. (chuckles)
So it is a very basic one, right?
It just doesn't do anything.
It doesn't have any kind of scoring.
It is not storing any
information over here.
So it's a very basic one
just for ideation, right?
Now, once I'm done with
the vibe coding, okay,
I have a plan now.
And now, what I want to do is
I want to add some features.
Like I want to store the player's score
and also the high score.
I want to add some visual
effects like some kind
of trail particles, some
kind of explosion effects,
and some sparkles like
when it passes through some obstacles.
So there's like a lot of
like additional features
that I want to add that means
that I'm gonna touch a lot
of like code base, as well
as I'm gonna create a lot
of additional files.
And I want this Kiro to kind of come up
with a plan before even
it starts coding, right?
So that's where like what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna switch over here.
So I'm gonna open a new context,
and then a new window.
And then, I'm gonna move to spec,
and this is where the fun will start.
So what I have told,
okay, help me add like
saved game history and scores, right?
I told about some of the visual effects,
and then I told create
a minimum viable product
for the above features.
And I wanted it to list
only five tasks rather
than going more granular.
Like if I don't give this
specific information,
it probably will come
up with like nine or 10
or maybe 11 steps, and it's very granular.
That's fine for some developers.
For the sake of today's time,
I just wanted to limit it
to five tasks.
So once I have given
that, I'm gonna hit enter.
And then, if you see, it now reads, again,
always like when it
starts doing something,
it always is looking into
the steering documents.
And then, now, it is reading
the existing code base.
And now, it started creating
the requirements document.
Now, if I hover over here,
and then if I go to specs,
it has created a folder.
And then, it has started creating
a requirements document for me.
And as I have shown you
the first time, I mentioned
that I want, so it has created
the requirements document,
and now it is waiting for me to like move
to design phase, which is the next step.
But before even I go
there is the user stories
and the acceptance criteria.
But what I mentioned is
that I mentioned give me
the personas as well, right?
So if you see over here, this is something
that it created based on my
specific global steering rules
where I mentioned introduce the personas
and tell me which user story is related
to which persona, right?
So if you see over here,
it has some user stories
and some of the personas attached
and what is the acceptance criteria?
So is the EIRs notation, right?
Now, if I have validated
everything looks good, I move
to design phase or else I can say, okay,
"Have you taken care
of deploying this code
"to AWS using serverless services?"
So if I, I can still chat, right?
Just like vibe coding, but I can ask,
"Okay, have you done that?"
Let's see, now, I haven't moved
into the design phase yet,
but then it says okay, no, the spec.
Okay, so it has come up
with another spec, focuses
on the game enhancement
features you requested,
and it says the current
game runs on HTML5.
If you would like to add AWS deployment
or backend, okay, save.
So it has given me, okay,
would you like to continue
with the spec as is for
visual or add AWS deployment?
So let's say I select two as an option.
And then, it goes back
and then updates the same
requirements documents.
So until and unless the
requirements is finalized
and I approve it, it's not gonna move
to the design phase, right?
And so, yeah, so if you see over here,
it has started updating the requirements.
And I can look like I can select here,
and you can see the diff.
So what is the additional
information that it is adding
on top of the existing one, right?
So it gets highlighted over here.
- [Marcus] Now, while it
creates those spec docs,
it refers back to the steering docs,
so that it makes sure
that it follows the rules
that you've given it.
And these requirements,
I mean, it's requirements
gathering, right?
That's one of the things that often misses
or gets missed in vibe coding.
And as we get further along, you'll start
to see how these specifications
are actually used
in validating the code
that the AI is creating or generating.
- [Pranjit] Yeah, so now, if
everything looks good, okay,
let's move to the design phase.
It's where I hit the design phase, right?
And then, I'll say, okay, comments good,
and then it went to the design phase.
All right, so let's go back here.
And then, I move to design.
So it's gonna start building the design,
which is basically the
technical architecture
and the Mermaid diagram
for me to validate, right?
Now, while it is doing that, I wanted
to showcase over here, like
when I select the ghosty button,
I have additional like
tools that I've added like
for example some of the existing
AWS-specific MCP servers,
like one for the documentation,
so that I always like
whatever I'm building, I want
to follow the best practices.
So I always want like Kiro to go
and look into the best
practices for that app,
like based on whether it's a server list
or a container-based, right?
So I want to follow that, so it can go
and look into these tools
using the MCP servers.
I want also like, and
I'm gonna do that, okay?
Like create an architecture diagram out
of the entire application that I've built.
So I can use the diagram MCP servers.
So there are additional like
third-party MCP servers,
like for example Fetch.
Like, let's say I'm building
a trading system application,
and there is
some existing trading system
applications out there.
I want to like ask Kiro to go
and check the URL of the trading system
and compare with the one that I'm building
or maybe any application,
and see if there's any additional features
that I want to use in
my application, right?
So it can go and like look
up existing like external URL
to come up with some
comparison and feature set
that I'm missing in my application.
So it can do a lot of like based
on what kind of MCP server
that you want to integrate.
The other thing, which is
important, is the agent hooks.
And this is very interesting,
and I'm gonna show you like
while it is building still
the design document, let me go
over here and this is something is built
on the event-driven architecture of AWS.
Whereas, let's say, I want this hook like,
"Whenever any code base
file is updated and saved,
"please do the unit testing
"to ensure it doesn't break
any existing feature."
So if that is a very basic like hook
that I want to use for an event-driven.
Like whenever a new file
or an existing file is
updated, I wanted the backend
for the agent to go and make
sure like nothing breaks
because of some additional
code that I've introduced
or updated an existing one.
So I can like create a hook.
And what it does is
that you can see like
it has execution queued.
That means the design
is still being created
when the execution is queued.
So I can open the task list,
so I can see like
multiple tasks right now.
So right now, if you see
it is in the design phase,
so it's doing the design document creation
whereas this task
creating the hook is still
in the queue, right?
So once the previous one is completed,
the next task is going to execute.
So you can see the queue
as well, all right?
Now, I'm gonna switch back
into my design, and let's see.
So there's an icon here where you want
to like look in a better one, okay?
So you can like even expand this,
and you can look into the
design in a better view.
Like, let me scroll this part of it,
so that it is much more
visible to all of you
so you can even look.
Okay, this is the high-level architecture
with the client side, server side,
and then the component
interaction flow and everything.
So you can look into the data model.
And then, it's still executing,
so let me wait over here.
Okay, so now, it has, yeah,
so it has now completed,
and it says are we good
with the design, right?
Now, I'm gonna close this one,
and then I'm gonna say,
okay, looks good to me.
Now, if you see over here, it's,
okay, so now it says, let
me see what it is doing.
Okay, so it has, perfect,
now, I will create the
implementation plan with task.
So that's the next step.
So until and unless that's
completed, it's still waiting
for the general spec.
That means the entire three
steps that it has to complete
before it creates the hook for me.
So now, if I hover over to the task list,
which is very interesting
where it gives you the granular task,
but if you see over here,
it's gonna create only five
of them for me.
Because I mentioned, okay,
don't create more than five tasks, right?
And if you see there are some
that are not highlighted,
which are like optional tasks.
So here, once a task list is created,
you can see there are a couple of options.
One is the keep optional
tasks that is faster MVP
or make all tasks record.
If I select this one, all
the non-highlighted ones
also becomes mandatory.
So all the task has to be like executed
before even I start the application.
But for the time being, I'm
not gonna do all the tasks.
I'm gonna just keep optional tasks.
So I hit that.
And now, it just tells, okay, perfect.
So now, it is going to
do only the five steps
that I mentioned, right?
And the optional testers
are marked as star,
so we can like skip them for a faster MVP.
Now, I can hover over here,
and I can look into the first task.
I can select that thunder
button next to the start task.
It's gonna start this task first,
and then it is going to wait for me to,
then once it is completed,
go to the next task.
Or else, I can do over here
execute all tasks in sequence.
Now, if I do that, you would see, okay,
now it started the first task, right?
And you can like look into view changes,
what it is doing, which,
okay, still not yet.
So you can, once it has
started editing some existing,
okay, so let's see, just executed.
Okay, now, it has executed the hook,
which is the one that I mentioned.
Okay, the hook is running right now.
That means some of the,
if you see over here,
which was interesting, it actually went in
and updated the game dot JavaScript file.
So hence, the auto unit testing
for the hook that I created
that whenever it updates the
existing file is gonna execute
the specific hook to ensure
that nothing breaks, right?
So it's still executing.
I can look into here.
It's waiting for that to execute,
and then it's still doing.
- [Marcus] Yeah, and this
is a good point to point out
when you create agent hooks,
this is something we created
that was very basic so that
you could see it in action.
But in a real development mode,
you're gonna choose
something that's meaningful
and impactful that's
going to be appropriate
for the amount of times it gets invoked.
And the second thing
that I was gonna point
out is you'll notice
there's broken up into tasks.
One of the reasons you may not want
to execute all tasks consistently
on a larger effort is
because we talked about a context window.
And these tasks, if you're
going along, you'll find
that Kiro also keeps track
of that context window.
And if you're doing a large
or a long development effort, it will stop
that session, start a new
context window, summarize it,
compact what's in your context memory,
and move it into a new session.
So one of the things you can
do with these tasks is usually
or use them to break up
your work, whether it's
because you've got a large
project that has multiple chunks
or because you want to
break up your context window
and have a clean window
for another large task,
so that your context window is clean
and works more efficiently
for you, giving you better answers
and getting faster processes.
- [Audience] Yeah, when it
does that auto compaction,
what does it do about agents
here, reinject them after?
- [Marcus] It does.
It brings over that summary,
and it brings those steering docs
and the spec docs back
into the new session.
- [Pranjit] Yeah, that's right.
And then, talking about
context window, right?
So I just invoked the Kiro
CLI within the IDE itself,
so you just like run the Kiro
hyphen CLI in the terminal.
And then, as Marcus
mentioned, like you can check
at runtime how much of context
window you are using, right?
So you can just type like slash context,
and you can see, okay,
I'm using like 12.8%
of the entire 100% context window.
And then, what are the
different like areas
that this context window
is filling up, right?
So you can see that on runtime.
And then, like the other thing
that is very important is like, let's say,
the first task is completed, right?
And it's still running the hook
for me doing the unit testing.
The first task, it addresses
these requirements.
So if you go to a requirements document
and see the 1.1, 1.2, right?
All these specific requirements,
it is basically tackling
through one single task, right?
So it also gives you that granularity
of like which requirements we
are actually completing, based
on which task.
And then, like the other thing
that is important is
like the checkpointing.
That means like, let's say, right now,
it is doing an execute hook unit testing.
And then, it has updated some of the like,
at the previous step, it
has updated some files.
I want to like, I probably have
done something wrong, okay?
Or I want to like revert back,
I have option of restore.
So if I select restore,
like I can just remove those.
I just,
I can just,
okay, it just, okay,
it's just like, okay,
so I think it did something wrong.
But what I wanted to say is
the restore option is like
you want to like re-update
the code base, okay,
to the previous state.
You can do that by executing
that restore button, right?
Okay, and let me stop this.
I think, let's see hook
enable for the time being.
But then, let me open the other thing.
Okay, so you mentioned
about the context window.
Let me bring that up.
So this is, let me show you here.
Okay, here is the thing.
I'm gonna bring this one.
So to your question,
and let me enlarge it,
here's the thing.
So I was building a, let's
say, a trading system, right?
And I deployed it on AWS.
Now, if you see over here,
let me go here.
This session was too long, right? For you.
So it did the compaction, right?
It basically went through
all the conversation history,
and then it created a
new session for me, okay?
With all the history for it.
So it has created a new session over here,
and then it did the same thing like,
if I go on the top like it,
again, including the steering documents.
So it came up.
Okay, I understood the previous context
from your conversation.
We did the compaction
of the context window,
and then, yeah, so it starts from there.
- [Marcus] And while you're
talking about this one
in particular, it's another
interesting call it with Kiro,
those tabs each have their own context.
So let's say you're working on something
that's more in depth in one tab
and you want to open up another tab
but keep that context
as clean as possible.
You can open up another tab,
just use Haiku in it, for example.
Have a conversation about
it, do some more planning,
maybe create some more
steering docs, some more specs,
more requirements, and then
work them back into the other
but keeping the other
context as clean as you can.
- [Pranjit] Yeah, so while
that is like executing, okay,
this is something that I already like,
for example, built it, right?
The same gaming application, right?
And what I did is that, okay,
the other thing is very important is like
if you are using any
kind of Git repo, right?
You want to commit, so the best practice
that we typically advise is like
whenever you have something,
which is a demo-able solution, right?
Do more Git commits, right?
Okay, connect with your Git repo, okay?
Do a commit, do an alternative, okay?
Anything, okay, this is
right time to commit it,
just commit it, and then come back
and like build on top of that, right?
So that you don't lose the code base
that you think you really like it.
So that's another best practice, right?
Now, if you see over here,
let's see which, okay, so,
here's the one thing, right?
So let's see which one is this one?
Okay, so it created a,
so this is an existing
gaming application, okay?
It did all the advanced
features that I mentioned.
And then, if I open the
gaming application with all the updates,
and then if I bring it over
here, I created a Pac-Kiro,
and it has ability to
save the high scoring,
it has those like trailing effects
that I mentioned and all that.
So I created this application
in like maybe less than 20 minutes, right?
Building that, so I can like use vibe,
like spec-based coding,
move from vibe coding,
for like doing proper planning,
approving all the requirements, design,
and task and everything.
And then, that's how like
you build like any kind
of production-ready application, which is,
and then the final thing is
like the AWS deployment, right?
So if you see over here in this one,
if I go back here.
Oh, no page. I'm struggling.
Okay, so I did like I told,
okay, even Kiro, right?
I asked, okay, can you
create an AWS cost analysis
because I'm very concerned about cost.
Okay, tell me like if there
are 10,000 users right now,
okay, using this application
when it is deployed on AWS,
how would that look like?
So it created an executive
summary for me, right?
Something like this.
So it went in and looked
into all the infrastructure
that it is using for
hosting this application.
And then, it did a cost
breakdown by service.
So it created a very detailed analysis
of like cost analysis.
The other thing is I asked him, okay,
can you create, like if I ask here,
can you create an AWS,
I think it is too small, right?
So architecture diagram
using AWS diagram server.
So this is something like, okay,
I have built the application,
but I want to create an
architecture diagram, right?
So it says, okay, I'll create
an architecture diagram
for you for the Pac-Kiro game.
Now, what it is doing is that
it is using the MCP tool.
So here, you have that diagram MCP server.
So it is taking all the icons from there,
and then it's creating an
architecture diagram for me.
And then, it's gonna wait for me.
And then, okay, I want to
allow it generate the diagram.
So you can like,
so this is something
more of a runtime, okay?
Where you are not like putting
everything into the context,
but you are like calling on runtime some
of the additional external tools, right?
And then, the other thing,
if you see over here,
there's another option here,
which is the hash button, right?
Okay, there is,
my screen froze on me for
some, okay, interesting.
My screen froze on me,
but then let me, so generate,
if you see over here,
this is a folder, it created
an architecture diagram for me.
Let me bring to this one.
Okay, that's a nice,
small architecture diagram
that it has created using
the diagram server, right?
Now, I don't know, I cannot,
okay, here is this.
So if you type hash,
and then there are like
certain additional contents
that you can inject.
Like let's say I have this URL,
and I can reference the URL like, okay,
I have as external URL
something like example.com.
And then, look into that,
look into this gaming application
and come up with a comparison
of the feature set that I want to utilize.
So you can like use spec-based coding
and the conversation with that
using some additional tools
that is there within the Kiro agentic IDE
to do some kind of
additional analysis use.
So that's kind of something,
which is very interesting, right?
Yeah, I think pretty much that's all.
Any questions so far based
on the IDE? Yep, go ahead.
- [Audience] I have a
little bit of a question.
- [Pranjit] Yeah.
- [Audience] Between the specs
and the steering you showed here,
we had a very fairly simple demo here,
but in a more mature application see
those getting quite longer.
- So-
- This is our concern
about the context window.
- [Marcus] Yeah, so the question is
pretty simple application, the steering
and the spec docs here, pretty small.
What does the context window look like
when you add a larger project?
You're doing a significant refactor
of an enterprise
application, what happens?
So that's when you start talking more
about you will have multiple phases.
You break the whole project
into phases as one piece,
and I'll come back and bring
it together in more detail.
Pranjit showed how some of these rules
and these steering docs are listed.
As always, you've got other options.
Don't always include them.
And also, so when you've
got multiple phases
of a project, you can
have different specs.
So I've got one example
that has 10 different specs,
and each spec has its own set
of requirements, design, and tasks.
An example, I could have the,
or I've got a particular enhancement.
I've got a new feature.
I got an MVP first that
took, you know, two specs.
Then, I'm like okay,
this is great for an MVP.
Everybody loved it.
Let's do some feature enhancements,
call it sprint one, sprint
two, whatever you've got.
And then, so you build that in there
and you create a spec doc for that set
of feature enhancements.
So I've got another spec
doc where I added a feature,
and I really want that feature,
but it broke some stuff.
So now, I've got another
spec and set of design
and implementation tasks that go back
and help me refactor that piece.
And so that's how you would do it.
Now, getting back to the context window,
if you haven't found it before
in your AI use as Models.dev,
it gives you a list of all
of the different models
that are, I don't know if it's all,
but most of the models that are out there.
You can see approximate
price per million tokens.
You can see size of the context window.
And when you look at that,
try to match the model
with the work that you're doing
because, yeah, could
you do a context show?
Like back in the Kiro CLI?
- [Pranjit] Yeah.
- [Audience] Do you guys have like a,
is there like a good ratio to shoot for?
- [Marcus] Yeah, we were
talking about ratios,
and it's interesting,
and it may not answer,
so the question was it
there a ratio we shoot for?
What I was gonna say is the context show,
you'll notice now I'm not getting just
how much is used per category.
I'm actually seeing what
files are being used.
That gives you a better
idea of what's being used
and what goes into it.
Do I really need this?
So ratio, the ratio that
we found is it could range,
when you're creating code,
you could have a simple,
you know, generate a spec
for doing an enterprise billing solution.
It could be 1:100.
You could do what Pranjit was doing,
which is a little more
detailed and constrain it,
and it's more of a 1:10, 1:20.
But one thing you'll find just
in general, context ratios
or token ratios, input/output,
is that what you're getting
at is inputs and outputs?
Okay, so input generating code,
1:10 to 1:100, depending upon things.
If you're doing translation, 1:1.
If you're doing something along the lines
of a summarization, it
might be just the opposite.
I've got 100:1 or 10:1
where I'm giving it this
and say summarize this for me.
So it's an inverse of that.
Just general Q and A, 1:3, 1:5.
I ask a question, you give me some degree
of concise or verbose answer.
But for what we're talking
about code development, it could range
from 1:10 to 1:100 ratio, depending
upon things like steering
docs, constraints,
and how you prompt it.
- [Pranjit] Yeah, it's typically like
if you input like I've seen
like at least for Kiro like
or some other tools like
it's like 100 input token,
you get one output token, right?
So that's the reason, right?
Like we consider context
window as the real estate
that you want to utilize it efficiently
because like you don't
want to dump everything
within the context
and like think like it's
gonna create something wonder
for you, right?
So very like important how you want
to utilize the context window.
That's all like this Kiro CLI
and the tools that you have
is like showing you those,
how you're utilizing the context window
and how you can like, are
you nearing to the compaction
and things like that.
You can do it even upfront, okay?
Like using some of the
commands like slash compact
and all that, right?
So yeah, that's important.
Now, like as I mentioned,
like I was just showing like
when you guys were having a conversation,
a trading system that I built, right?
Okay, so you can build like
this is just for like the time
of that we have like an hour, okay?
How we can showcase some of the features
and some of the tools
that are there within the
Kiro agentic IDE, okay?
Which will help you from our
context engineering side of it.
Right now, we have gone through
this like just a summary
of what we went over.
We used like vibe coding to
start the ideation phase,
then we moved to the spec-based coding,
and then we like it
created the user stories
and acceptance criteria,
the requirements phase.
Just like any SDLC
process, we call it AIDLC
or artificial intelligence DLC, right?
And then, the design phase is
where you are gonna look into
all the architecture diagram,
the Mermaid flow, the system
architecture and everything.
And then, once you are
fine with those, you move
to the task, which can be more granular
and where you have like
additional optional task as well,
which you can make them
like mandatory, right?
And there's one very
important thing that was like
after it went GA just a few weeks back,
a property-based testing or PBT,
which is basically not just unit testing
of just a specific module
that you have developed
with agentic IDE, but making sure like
if you're doing some code update
or creating new code, is it gonna go back
and look into the requirements document
and see like if it is like aligning
to what you initially set to build, right?
So the property-based
testing is something,
it talks about like correctness property.
And then, it's basically embedded
within the design markdown file
where you go scroll all the way down,
it shows all the property-based testing.
Like these are the property
testing that is aligned
to these requirements,
and it's gonna check those, okay,
at certain interval based on
what you are building, right?
Using some of the tasks.
So those are the important things.
And then, you come up
with a working product.
Now, some of the advantages
both for developers
and for the organizations
like you reduce time
for fixing some of the code
that you generate through AI.
You build production-ready solutions
from day one rather
than just like prompting
and praying something good comes out.
You become a context architect,
not just a code reviewer, right?
So you're gonna use your
own knowledge, right?
That you have acquired
from so long working
on different tools and
technologies and frameworks, right?
So that's very important.
That's not gonna go away.
And also, how you can use,
like if you're building
on AWS, the best practices,
like I've shown some
of the MCP server there are like more
like cost-related MCP server.
There's like cloud formation MCP server
and all those things.
Like there's like more than 50
of them already out there, right?
And then, from the organization, okay,
they're gonna not gonna get
a very big AWS bill just
because like AI code
didn't even like understand
the cost implications
of like is it building something?
Like is it like spinning up big containers
or easy instances,
things like that, right?
So very important.
And then, some of the security
and compliance, like mostly
for financial industry,
insurance industry,
how you are dealing with
PHI, PII data, right?
Are there any other government standards
that it has to adhere to, right?
You can do those vibe coding
and the spec-based coding.
You can like have that conversation
and like make sure those are like embedded
within the markdown
files or add those phases
before even you start coding.
So plan before you build,
right? That's kind of the idea.
And then, faster time to
market and the tech dev, right?
Like when you do vibe coding,
okay, you gather a lot
of like technical dev
because like there's a
lot of unnecessary code
that is not needed, right?
So how you can improve that
and reduce some of the tech dev,
so those are some of the
benefits for the organizations.
And this is something that
I wanted to highlight.
Like Andrej Karpathy, you
probably know the founder
of OpenAI, one of the
co-founders has mentioned in one
of his session, LLMs are the new CPUs,
which is more of like
context processing unit.
So context is very important.
And how you move from prompt engineering
to the context engineering is the new era
that we are gonna go into right next year.
So as I mentioned, some of the resources,
these are some of the QR codes.
Please, take a picture if you want.
The first one is very interesting,
which is like the context
engineering versus vibe coding,
when to use what.
It's not and or all, it's basically based
on all your use case, okay?
If you're building a quick prototype
for going into a meeting, okay,
where you want to just show the art
of the possible, probably
vibe coding is the way to go.
But if you're planning
to build a production-ready application,
it's not the right step, right?
The Kiro website to get
started, how you can download
and set up your WorkSpaces.
And then, this is an interesting workshop
like AI-driven dev with Kiro workshop.
This takes you to the workshop of the AWS
where you can like actually do hands-on,
how you can use vibe coding, spec-based,
and some of the other additional resources
that are shared today.
Like some of the additional features.
And with that, I think we
come to the conclusion.
This is our email address
if you want to connect
or like connect over LinkedIn.
And please, like feedback is a gift.
So if there's anything
that we can improve upon,
if there's anything
that we didn't meet your
expectations, based on the sessions
that we have, please feel free
to give your honest feedback, right?
So yeah, any questions? We have some time.
- [Audience] I know we talk a lot
about, you know, VOC
that you (indistinct),
what about legacy code or existing code?
Can you give some practices?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, microservices
and you're just getting
started over there.
What are some steps that we should follow
for existing large applications?
- [Pranjit] Yeah, so let me
rephrase for the audience,
for someone who is going
to offline hear this.
The question is basically
what are the legacy applications, right?
Like how do we modernize
or how do you like start,
or like playing with those?
And like this was the
same question I was having
with someone else.
Like there's the use case over here.
Okay, it's just one, like two patterns
that we have showed here.
There are like a hundred
types of patterns.
So one of the patterns that we
have seen is like there is a,
and just to give an example,
a legacy Java application, right?
That's been running for like 10, 15 years
with some outdated Java version,
some of the security challenges, right?
So there was this use case
where like the stakeholders
are really concerned
and they want to migrate to
a more modern architecture,
but it's a lot of significant investment
for the key resources.
Probably, the developers
that have built, okay,
have left the organization, right?
So how do you like squeeze that timeframe
and use Kiro, right?
To give that code base,
like point to the code base,
and then let it like use the
spec-based coding to come up
with a modern, cloud native.
Like if it cloud is the right way, come up
with the discovery and
the analysis part of it,
and what would be the 2B architecture?
So you can do all that roadmap analysis
and come up with that plan
in a detailed fashion, okay,
which you can use like
once you get approval
from your stakeholders to
kind of then start building
on like small task or sublevel tasks
when addressing some of
the specific components
within the legacy application
to move to a more modern
cloud-native architecture.
It's like a crawl, walk,
runs process, right?
That we typically follow.
So there's use cases over there.
Okay, we have workshops
of how you can get started
on dealing with some of
the legacy applications
and how we can use that Kiro
to kind of build modern architecture
and like modernize the legacy application.
So there are use cases
around that as well, okay?
- [Marcus] If I can
add my two cents, agree
with everything he just
said, but I got two minutes.
I think I can enhance it.
- [Audience] So bringing application
on the cloud, already (indistinct).
- [Marcus] Yep.
- [Audience] It's just
now continue development
in that application (indistinct)?
- [Marcus] Greenfield's
really easy, right?
It's the brownfield that you gotta do
a little more work on it.
So you've got an enterprise
architecture diagram, right?
Or if not, make one.
Or have Claude, Kiro help you.
But Claude is multi or Kiro is multimodal.
So you can take a picture or an image
of that enterprise diagram, feed it in,
and then start at that level.
And then, you know,
provide anything you want
about your microservices architecture.
Do you wanna change everything?
Are you updating for versions, et cetera?
But something you can go back
to your hotel room tonight,
get the diagram, feed it
into Kiro as an image and say,
help me develop a solution
for updating, upgrading, refactoring,
whatever you need to do.
Start from there. Work your
way down into the details.
Break up each one of those microservices
into its own set of specs.
- [Pranjit] All right, if
there's no any questions,
we'll wrap up here.
But thank you, again, for staying with us.
Hopefully, it was helpful.
And yeah, thank you.
(audience applauding)